الموسم الخامس من ذاكرهون ربما يكون
الاكثر جدلا منذ بدايه عرض العمل في 2016
الانتقادات تركز على ان خيال المؤلف ثم
فرضه على انه واقع المسلسل يعبد احداثا
عصرناها بالفعل وان كانت هناك بعض التوابل
لاضافه نكهه واثاره على الاحداث نتفليكس
لا تنكر ذلك لا تدافع ان العمل ليس
وثائقيا
يتناول موسم جديد فتره التسعينات وهو
العقد الاكثر حساسيه في تاريخ العائله
الملكه العقد الذي كتب نهايه لثلاث جيجات
وشهد حريق وانصر الشهير عام 1992 حدث
القرن مقتل البيانو
بعد وفاه الملكه اصبح اي تصوير سلبي
لابنها تشارلز اكثر دقه لان ذلك يعني
انتقاد الملك الحالي بسوره المباشره واحد
الامثله عرض المكالمه الحميميه المسربه
بين تشارلز وكامل نقد اخر كان بطل
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الاسبق الذي وصف
مشهد محادثته مع ملكه تشارلز وتدبيره
للاطاحه بالملكه اليزابيث من العرش على
انه محظوراء
التلميح على ان الامير فيلكانا على علاقه
ب 30 عاما اثار الجدل ايضا حيث تصير مصادر
مقربه من العائله المالكه على انها كانت
مجرد صديقه ليس لها